i am one of the specialists in
computational structure biology and and
also
ngs data so i've been able to work on
several
different bioinformatics projects
throughout my career so that also
includes
association with pharma and uh academic
career translational projects so i've
been working
on on for almost 12 years and have
all of that experience to help you with
your own project so my here role is
in prime better my major role is to
develop these partnerships with
collaborators such as universities
companies and also like
be a project mentor to students who
would need
guidance to you know go to the next step
so
about that experience i think summer
this summer we have had an
amazing opportunity for all of you to
come
interact with us and learn from us a a
peer-reviewed panel so let me tell you
more about the
uh the upcoming programs and how
there could be a possibility to for you
to now work on your course work like
helia
like her treat uh sorry like sonalika
india all of us
have been talking about that start your
basic training or start your project
right now
so that you can be uh you know future
ready and
you can be also uh utilizing the
upcoming resources
in june and especially in the month of
june and july
so we have this ongoing program with
faba academy which is a special wing
under
organization that focuses on grooming of
students
of university nationwide and make them
ready for industry and academia
so to help with the awareness and to
contribute
this summer uh we are bringing this
unique opportunity for students and
researchers to join the research
fellowship program
and get feedback from an elite team of
industry and academy experts and mentors
to learn and apply data-driven research
for drug discovery
so uh let me just quickly introduce you
some of these researchers and
scientists and mentors and ceos who
would be helping you out
throughout this time so in the lower
panel
uh we have uh dr ajeet kamath
he has a 25 years plus experience or on
pre-clinical drug discovery
and his work was primarily at pfizer uh
which is pfizer r d in usa uh
next we have dr chakra mesha so he has a
background in drug discovery high
throughput screening biochemistry
pharmacology
so for 25 years he's been working with
roche and
syntax and dr ramesha laboratory
that conduct research uh focused on
identification and characterization of
drug targets
drug candidates for multiple uh disease
targets
so a lot of experience they are working
on several pharma projects
and also drug discovery
pipeline so other than that we have dr
uda saxena he's a co-founder of a
startup biotech called rainy gen
innovation he has published more than 60
papers and have
a lot of 28 patents for to be specific
so he serves as a review uh member for
many of the panels and he will be also
he is also a mentor
so he'll be also guiding students uh
there
dr rama reddy here is a former scientist
and founder of aragon pharmaceuticals
uh and he was one of the scientists in
scene at aragon pharmaceuticals which is
now
bought by pfizer santiago so now
dr reddy is working on bioinformatics
chemi informatics and computational
chemistry
and one of his uh
[Music]
work at pfizer led to i mean there are
several clinical candidates with with
which he has worked with
like cancer and but one of the fda
approved drug for aids which was
which had his work was veera set
so also we have pranit kakkar kunikar is
a drug discovery scientist
working as a uh as uh in accenture india
he comes with an experience of a more
than a decade about chemi informatics
and
computational drug discovery and drug
designing so this will be one of the
opportunities in the in the upcoming
month uh to work and able to you know
translate your research
and then work on drug discovery aspect
and also learn about
uh molecules and get uh you know
feedback so uh
another program that is with the same
collaborators is
uh machine learning for biomedical
research in this program which will be
starting obviously on 14 june you can
see right here on the slides
uh on the slide so in this program we
will learn to load
explore visualize and analyze biomedical
data using big data analytical tools
and we'll be using uh coding in r and
python
and here it will be like really a
great experience because we will also be
working on
a neural network machine like deep
learning
nlp computer vision so i'm looking into
the
analysis of images also to looking into
the analysis of text
and then we will also learn about
machine learning for small molecules
and uh learn about convoluted
convolution neural networks
and processing of an analysis of omics
data as well
so we will be also applying it for
variety of data that is out there
for biomedical research so this program
will start on 14th june
and uh people who are joining the
research fellowship
will be able to access some of the uh
resources
from these programs so the second
program is of course the kemi
informatics program which we
kind of which i kind of discussed
earlier but i mean to give you an
introduction i mean give you an
overview it will be about the
introduction of all the chemical
like all of structures chemical
interactions databases
so we'll be learning about virtual
screening hits hit identification
uh qsr docking heat to lead modification
admin profiling all of that
and this uh program will also have a
workshop dedicated workshop
by stradenger so uh that would be an
additional thing
uh with all that we will be covering uh
so
one should like leading from the
genomics transcriptomics drug discovery
uh to you know target discovery to to
finding molecules and then to be able to
work on that
so that's kind of a complete modern drug
discovery pipeline
that we are envisioning with uh this
summer and
we will also have an opportunity for
students who would be doing all of this
and uh generate some data and
information from themselves
like projects and then to be able to you
know
present that project in a symposium that
will be uh again
in august uh scheduled for august and
there we will have
several of these mentors helping our
students who finish these projects or
are completing these projects
for example uh genomics in the virtual
lab so genomics in the virtual lab is
another opportunity uh to work with a
world renowned scientist and a team of
bioinformatician
so in this program we will have
association from multiple partners in
including dr sona vasudevan she is a
professor of biochemistry and molecular
biology
at george georgetown university medical
center washington dc
so she will be also presenting uh
disease uh
associated projects uh and also helping
the participants to learn
how genomics is used at the interaction
intersections or intersection of data
science and bioinformatics
so again this is another opportunity to
be
able to work with a renowned scientist
and a team
and that team includes a team of experts
perhaps
bioclues is one of our close associates
so together with uh you know pine
biotech and bioclues we see a common
mission
uh to develop a new generation of
computational biologists across
asia so group of bioinformaticians top
scientists and researchers from bioclues
will also be helping students
and mentor bioinformatics projects on
agriculture neuroscience oncology
immunology
and other topics so all those
opportunities will be available for you
in the summer to work with us
and get guidance from experts in the
field
another program that we have is
precision medicine as ilya was telling
about
telling you all about the christian
medicine program this will be
sorry this will be also in june and here
we will be learning about examples of
chronic and acute infectious diseases
uh on political oncolytic viruses
and also cancer problem with
basic and translational on oncology
research
so this program will also be supported
by
uh by by our counterparts in sri lanka
so the precision medicine program will
be available
through our collaborators and students
in sri lanka to get work with
uh get to work with this translational
team
at nishte so these are some of the
opportunities that are there and as you
are connecting with us and
joining the learn platform and also the
social media networks
we will be sharing these informations to
you via email
and also why all those networks but if
you will be joining the
uh research fellowship program obviously
you'll be getting all those updates
and uh link to the sessions and also
resources
that will be uh for this uh entire
summer uh
we have so this summer would be a great
opportunity to work on
and develop something and be really
proud of it because end of uh
at the end of the summer we'll be able
to come up and
you know work with students to finish
projects learn much
learn different aspects of biological uh
biological data types
and also to apply machine learning and
other important techniques that are
really relevant to today's
biomedical research and also for
academic or any other research
so that's what i wanted to talk to you
all about and
show you the opportunities uh that are
upcoming
so now i'll just uh pass it on to or may
pass it to
uh sonalika uh to conclude the session
and uh say goodbye uh dr mohit we have a
question that's coming up again that
what is the difference between the three
months fellowship program and the six
months fellowship program
could you please elaborate on that and
explain it to them i thought we can take
it
this question over here to make them
understand
in a better way absolutely yeah i mean
uh i have been working with several
students and yesterday we got a
publication coming up uh
by semai and i think uh i think uh
sonalika if you can share that link uh
with
with students as well so uh our research
projects uh project
is uh is a challenging thing to do is a
challenging
work so the research projects start from
you know understanding the basic
i mean getting the getting to learn
about the basic
understanding of how to learn and apply
these technologies such as genomics
transcriptomics metagenomics on all
those uh
areas so it depends kind of depends on
your research project what are your
interest in
what is your interest in so what what
technologies you will be applying
to your research project so based again
on on based on that and how the research
is progressing how much time you are
able to give
so basically we have this three month
option and six month option
so in three months of option uh if you
are starting from zero
so if you if you are starting if you
don't have a
background and as as many of us have
been
elaborating and discussing that you need
to go through some of the course
material that are there
so if you're going through the course
material and then doing a project it's
going to take you time
so i think for those who would want to
go through
example projects discuss all of that
understand the application
of bioinformatics in different disease
types and then come up with their own
project to
i mean kind of become prepared and then
going for a project that
for those i would like to you know
recommend a six-month
uh six-month uh project
uh to be able to come up with a
publication or to have
like those sort of goals for people who
are joining
uh for three months i mean it depends
again on the ability and
uh the time that you are giving to this
uh this uh
initiative of this fellowship so in that
case
i think you will have to
[Music]
give more time to finish the project and
everything in three months from writing
report
to maybe writing a draft to
doing a video presentation so we have
had several examples where people were
able to do it in
a very short amount of time for example
three months but
again i mean that is something is which
is variable from person to person
so both of the opportunities are there
and if you if you feel that you have not
been able to complete and you can
obviously
there's an option to extend as well